[Music]
shark fin soup is steeped in tradition
with recipes dating back over two
thousand years when it was served
exclusively for Chinese emperors
here in Taipei it's everywhere an entire
fin per Bowl
it tells the demand it's huge a much
bigger scale than I could ever imagine
back home is always still as a trade
using money where we want to spend 30 40
quid 50 quid on a policy and they come
to Taiwan for the first time and [ __ ]
everyone's eating it everybody from
street corner cafes to fine dining
restaurants it's everywhere
I've come to one of the city's most
exclusive restaurants Imperial to taste
the soup for the very first time keys
Fang sharp friend chef Chan Chi Quan
doesn't speak English but the maitre d
David is here to help me out
[Music]
because it's amazing broth that's been
cooking now for a sort of eight to ten
hours and its flavor with ham he's just
talking it with some soy sauce but sort
of salty slightly smoked flavor to it
the shark fins have been steamed soaked
and washed for days and then left to
infuse in a basic chicken stock until
the textures de latinus 90 pounds for
that yes Jesus 70 quid so 90 quid 70
pound and this small one
[Music]
so that's about 25 quit the quality of
finish just by size and thickness
the broth is added to a heated clay pot
and once boiling the fin goes in
right and that's it finish
as you'd expect I've gone for the most
expensive bowl so to do some garnish
little bit more vinegar some bamboo
shoots
that's a coriander so the idea is to
peel back the thin was a taste of real
proper shopping soon
[Music]
I mean it's really
[Music]
many bizarre I mean really bizarre
because actually takes up nothing almost
like sort of plain glass noodles
[Music]
delicious really good but it could have
anything in there gonna have a chicken
sweet corn it could have duck it's just
wrong belly so I want to ask the
customers why they're prepared to spend
so much money on something that to me
tastes of nothing that table of the IP
yes they've spent 90 pound each on a
bowl of soup and they're denying me
access into the dining room
have you got a piece of paper please the
pen and piece of paper the paper basin I
just
I'm sorry